[Musica]
tutta sta diventando una palla deve
andare in palestra ragazzi agi
anzi oggi mi vado a fare leggi il cubo
cosa ci crede nessuno è una sfida mai 3
[Musica]
il momento di proporti una sfida
dobbiamo riuscire a fare delle cose di
yoga accoppia con delle tutine da
ballerine faccio vedere io faccio vedere
di non uscire abbiamo semplice
questa no questa gamma
ci vediamo quest'altra io siamo sotto di
fare questo con le mani io ritengo per i
giorni ci siamo adesso
[Applauso]
ok in piedi su animali non si vedono
di questo passo si
[Applauso]
g ci siamo di 35 anni che ci sono ha
bisogno che ce l'abbiamo
non andiamo a mangiare così facile
questo è facile
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video io ringrazio ancora con
tutto il mio cuore jill cooper mi sono
divertita da morire quando vuoi oneri
butta nella mischia poi breve
ovviamente questa città il buio alcuni
calcoli fatti dai ragazzi poi ditelo e
se siete d'accordo con me lo voglio
mettere sotto torchio perché secondo me
il suo corpo potrebbe diventare tifoso
belle ma un pesce vorrei in altri
allenati sul serio 26 e facciamola foto
prima e dopo ci sto a yahoo